J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, là, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez.
Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Mais bonjour, on se retrouve aujourd'hui pour un épisode sur le Congo belge, donc le Congo durant sa période coloniale, sous le règne de la Belgique et du roi Léopold II juste avant ça.
Vous le savez, c'est un sujet dont on est tous vaguement conscients. On est au courant qu'il s'est passé des choses au Congo, au début du XXe siècle, mais on nous apprend pas ça à l'école.
Donc c'est pour la plupart des gens relativement obscur, abscons. Je me demandais comment j'allais pouvoir gérer un épisode comme ça.
Je me suis dit qu'il fallait que je fasse un épisode
entier pour expliquer et revenir un peu sur l'histoire, un peu comme ce qu'on avait fait il y a quelques années avec Tal Bruttmann, sur l'histoire de l'antijudaïsme, antisémitisme et antisionisme.
Puis un deuxième épisode pour analyser tout ça. J'ai eu beaucoup de chance de trouver un charmant invité, Mathieu Zana Etambala, qui est professeur donc à la KU Leuven, historien, puisqu'au final, on a réussi à faire les deux en un seul épisode.
Donc on revient un petit peu sur les points marquants, on va dire, du Congo colonial,
en passant donc par le caoutchouc rouge, l'assassinat de Patrice Lumumba, la période de la Deuxième Guerre mondiale, voilà, les débuts avec
le règne de Léopold II.
Et en deuxième partie, on se penche sur des éléments plus contemporains, avec notamment la fameuse commission parlementaire qui était dédiée à ces questions il y a quelques années, la question des musées en Belgique, la question de,
pourquoi est-ce qu'en fait, on n'en parle pas dans nos écoles ?
Bref, dans tous les cas, que vous soyez déjà super informé au sujet du Congo belge ou que, comme moi, avant de réaliser cet épisode, vous soyez relativement ignorant, puisque-- et je pense que c'est le cas de la grande majorité des
gens, puisque encore une fois, on n'en parle pas du tout dans l'enseignement.
Dans tous les cas, cet épisode devrait vous plaire. Il y en a pour tous les goûts. Sans plus attendre, Mathieu Zana Etambala.
J'ai le plaisir d'être aujourd'hui avec Mathieu Zana Etambala. Bonjour Mathieu.
Bonjour.
Vous êtes historien à la KU Leuven, vous êtes spécialiste de l'histoire coloniale belge, notamment en ce qui concerne donc forcément le Congo, les relations belgo-congolaises et forcément la période de domination.
Déjà, merci d'avoir accepté l'invitation.
Le plaisir est à moi.
Alors, je vais d'abord m'adresser à vous avant de se rapprocher du Congo. Qu'est-ce qui a fait que vous avez choisi de vous intéresser à ce sujet ?
On sait que vous avez des racines, forcément, avec le Congo. Qu'est-ce qui vous a amené vers ce travail de recherche ?
Ben écoutez, je suis né à Léopoldville, à Kinshasa. C'était encore à l'époque coloniale, en 1955.
Et je suis arrivé ici en Belgique, surtout, enfin, c'est-à-dire dans une famille en Flandre occidentale, où j'ai fait presque toutes mes études.
Et j'ai choisi l'histoire parce que cela, enfin, c'est quelque chose qui m'intéresse beaucoup depuis, enfin, depuis que j'avais douze, douze ou treize ans.
Il faut savoir que à ce moment-là, quand j'arrive à l'université, en 1972, septante-trois, il n'y avait rien sur l'histoire de la colonie belge ni de l'État indépendant du Congo.
Mh.
Mais j'ai quand même tout de suite eu l'occasion de me préparer. C'est-à-dire, il y a eu des professeurs qui acceptaient, donc, de m'accompagner dans mes études africaines.
Comme ça, j'ai commencé à travailler sur le mouvement politico-prophétique, le kibanguisme, sur la présence ou les présences des Congolais en Belgique.
Mais, c'est-à-dire, j'ai dû-
Vous êtes parti de rien.
On est parti de rien, vraiment de rien.
On va effectivement avoir l'occasion de discuter de l'importance de ces études dans l'enseignement en Belgique et-
Mh.
...dans la sphère universitaire, parce qu'il y a des choses à dire à ce niveau-là. Mais donc, en tant qu'historien,
quelle est la responsabilité en tant qu'historien, pour ce qui est de donner forme à la compréhension qu'on a en Belgique de, voilà, de la période coloniale ?
Puisque on sait que généralement, quand on parle avec des, par exemple, des jeunes Belges qui ont trente ans comme moi, c'est assez absent de l'enseignement et on sait finalement assez peu de choses puisque on nous a appris assez peu de choses.
Mh. Ben, écoutez, il y a une chose que les gens doivent comprendre, c'est que l'histoire a toujours été écrite par les vainqueurs.
Mh.
Et donc, à partir de la fin du XIXe siècle, en ce qui concerne le Congo, c'était les Belges, Léopold II tout d'abord, qui ont commencé à dominer, donc qui étaient les vainqueurs.
Parce que les Belges, les Européens ne sont pas arrivés au cœur de l'Afrique centrale sur la demande des Congolais, des Africains.
C'était une invasion, parce que les Congolais n'avaient rien à voir avec ces gens-là qui, venus de plus de dix mille kilomètres de chez eux.
Donc jusqu'en 1960, les Belges sont restés les vainqueurs, c'est eux qui écrivaient l'histoire. Et quand on est-- qui sont en fait ceux qui écrivent l'histoire, qui sont les vecteurs de l'histoire.
En fait, il y en a trois. Il y a toujours l'État. Il y a, à cette époque-là, les grandes églises, l'Église catholique, par l'évangélisation, donc de l'Afrique, enfin, au moins de l'Afrique centrale.
Et puis il y a toutes ces sociétés industrielles ou concessionnaires, je dirais, d'origine belge. Et ça, comment est-ce qu'on peut le savoir ?
C'est très simple. À chaque anniversaire, par exemple pour des grandes sociétés de charte du Congo, c'est-à-dire l'Union minière, la Forminière, etc.
À chaque, après vingt-cinq ans, il y a des livres de luxe sur ce que cette société avait réalisé au Congo.
Donc pour les églises-
Vous pensez aux grandes marques comme Côte d'Or, etc. ?
Oui, oui. Pour le Congo, c'est surtout l'Union minière-
D'accord.
...donc le cuivre dans le Katanga.
Et le caoutchouc.
Le caoutchouc, ça, c'était avant. Mais jusqu'à très récemment, il y a eu très peu d'études sur cette période, sur le régime caoutchoutier de Léopold II.
Parce que ça s'est mal terminé avec, euh-
C'est ça.
...une enquête, donc, qui a quand même démontré que il y a eu des abus, des excès, des atrocités, etc.
Ça ne va plus, ça s'est mal terminé.
Oui, oui.
Même, oui, sur-
La reprise, en conséquence, c'était la reprise donc de l'État indépendant du Congo par la Belgique, en 1908. Et-
Qui à la base était un projet, entre guillemets, personnel, donc du roi Léopold II.
C'est ça, c'est ça. Il faut dire qu'il avait beaucoup investi en ça, mais il a aussi tiré beaucoup de profit de tout cela.
Et les gens ne peuvent pas oublier que la première mesure que Léopold II a prise, son premier décret, c'était la confiscation des terres des Congolais.
Oui.
C'était une confiscation pure et simple. C'était du jamais vu
dans l'histoire de l'humanité. Donc dire, une région quatre-vingt fois plus grande que la Belgique, soudainement, cela appartient à une personnalité, c'est-à-dire le roi souverain.
C'était du jamais vu. Et donc, ce qui s'est produit après l'annexion de l'État indépendant du Congo par la Belgique, on a essayé, d'un côté, d'oublier ce qui s'était fait, donc ces atrocités, cela.
On ne voulait plus en parler. Et de l'autre, c'était montrer, prouver, disons, les aptitudes coloniales de la Belgique.
Donc que la Belgique soit une puissance coloniale digne de ce nom-là.
Et à ce niveau-là, elle était relativement en retard par rapport à ses voisins de l'Europe de l'Ouest.
Oh oui, oui, oui.
Dernière de la classe, entre guillemets, pour dire ça comme ça.
Ah oui, oui, oui.
Et donc, ce que vous disiez sur la confiscation des terres, c'est presque une colonisation
très très accélérée comparée à ce que, voilà, on a pu voir, par exemple,
avec les Anglo-Saxons et l'Amérique du Nord, où ça s'est fait de façon assez, voilà, ça s'est fait sur des dizaines d'années, avec des rachats de terres, des choses comme ça.
Ici, le roi Léopold II est arrivé au Congo et s'est décidé : bon, on va faire ça, on va se dépêcher.
Oui, et tout le monde acceptait cela. Il y a eu-
En Belgique, en tout cas.
En Belgique, oui. Et il faut dire, après un certain temps, au début du XXe siècle, même les Anglo-Saxons ont accepté cela.
Parce que les terres confisquées, ils donnaient cela en concession
aux sociétés coloniales comme l'Union minière, etc. Et c'était avec le capital anglo-saxon qu'on a effectivement exploité cela, parce qu'en Belgique, on n'avait pas suffisamment d'argent.
C'était un capitalisme, je ne dis pas plus doux, mais moins performant que le capitalisme anglo-saxon. Donc-
La grande industrie comme chez nos voisins.
Oui, oui, oui. Ryan, tout ça, donc qui ont fait. Et donc à ce moment-là, on voit que la Belgique continue cette politique de concession, en ce qui concerne le régime foncier.
Le régime qui donnait des concessions. Bon, on a continué. L'Union minière, Forminière s'adaptait. Donc ça a été créé par Léopold II en 1906, mais la Belgique a continué cette politique-là.
Il faut dire que la politique coloniale de la Belgique était quand même un peu plus humanitaire, humaine que la politique de Léopold II.
Et c'est ça qu'on voit pendant toute cette période-là, disons, à partir de 1876, 1885 et puis jusqu'en 1960,
c'est qu'on considérait que les indigènes n'avaient pas d'histoire ou que leur histoire ne commençait qu'avec la pénétration blanche.
Donc, à partir du moment où la Belgique a repris, il y a eu, pour dire ça comme ça,
une considération pour employer un vocabulaire d'aujourd'hui, pour les ressources humaines et pour le fait qu'il fallait éviter les massacres, que ça n'allait pas pouvoir durer sur le temps long.
Oui. Mais la colonisation, il faut aussi définir cela d'une manière correcte. Donc la société coloniale, ça consistait en deux communautés.
Deux communautés, c'est-à-dire une communauté blanche minoritaire mais dominante et une communauté noire majoritaire, mais dominée.
Et c'est pour ça que je dis toujours : est-ce qu'on peut considérer ça comme, disons, la colonisation ou cette société-là, comme des sociétés démocratiques ?
Non. Non, non, non. Et donc on a toujours essayé de justifier cela, de contextualiser, etc. Mais l'historien n'a rien à contextualiser.
L'historien n'a rien à justifier. Il y a des faits que l'on doit interpréter et de manière juste. Et bien sûr, nous sommes tous des enfants de notre temps, de notre culture.
Mais il faut,
à l'heure actuelle, et c'est ça mon combat ces derniers mois, j'ai été fort malade et donc j'ai repris mes activités depuis peu de temps, c'est de faire comprendre aux Belges, parce que
même lors de la colonisation belge, de la colonie belge, il y a eu, c'est un phénomène que j'ai fort étudié.
Enfin, je peux me considérer comme un Kibangologue, donc la contestation des Bas-Congo en 1921 contre le régime colonial belge.
De 1921 jusqu'en 1939, plus de six cent Congolais ont été arrêtés et déportés, parfois à plus de mille, mille cinq cent, deux mille kilomètres de chez eux, de leur foyer.
Simon Kibangu, qui est considéré un peu comme la tête de ce mouvement, il a été condamné à mort. Et puis bon, on a quand même commué ça en service pénal, la déportation à Lubumbashi.
Mais encore une fois, Simon Kibangu n'avait frappé aucune personne, aucun Belge. Il n'avait tué personne.
Mais parce qu'il voulait la libération, enfin la liberté de pensée et de religion de ces gens-là, on considérait ça comme contre l'ordre colonial.
On l'a poursuivi et on l'a condamné à mort. Tandis que dans cette histoire coloniale, il y a eu des officiers et des sous-officiers blancs, belges et autres,
qui ont parfois massacré des villages entiers, qui n'ont jamais été condamnés pour cela, pour ne pas dire condamnés à mort.
Donc quand on parle de la justice coloniale, moi, je dis toujours que c'est une sorte de contradictio in terminis, parce que justice et colonisation, on peut pas associer les deux.
La colonisation est en soi une forme d'injustice.
Et pour comprendre ce que vous expliquiez il y a quelques instants, comme quoi c'était une majorité
noire dominée par une minorité blanche dominante, pour comprendre cette colonisation il est indispensable, je pense, de penser tout cela à travers le racisme.
Ah oui, oui, oui, mais enfin, ça, bon parce que le racisme, et ça, j'essaie toujours de faire comprendre ça à mes étudiants.
Le racisme ne date pas donc de la période coloniale. Mais avant cela, avant leur arrivée, avant la pénétration donc des Européens au cœur de l'Afrique, ils étaient déjà racistes.
Parce que tout a été précédé par l'esclavagisme ou la traite des Noirs. Donc on considérait les Noirs, en fait, comme des objets, qu'on pouvait-
C'était déjà une évidence à ce stade-là.
C'était déjà une évidence, comme vous venez de dire, disons, durant le dernier quart du dix-neuvième siècle, donc ce mépris pour le Noir.
Et à ce moment-là, l'Europe était aussi plus religieuse qu'aujourd'hui, donc le poids des églises catholiques et des églises protestantes qui acceptaient le fait que, c'était l'histoire sainte, que
les Africains étaient les descendants donc d'un enfant maudit de Noé.
Donc la malédiction de la race noire. Donc pour les églises, c'était des gens, comment dirais-je, inférieurs.
Des sous-personnes.
Des blancs manipulateurs.
Donc c'était dans la tête, dans le chef des Blancs, déjà avant d'arriver là-bas.
C'est ça. Les Blancs manipulaient que ce soit la science ou la religion pour pouvoir inscrire dans le marbre l'idée que tout ça était parfaitement légitime et évident.
Oui, oui, oui. Ils employaient cela, c'est-à-dire, c'était une forme d'abus, d'abus mental, scientifique.
Et après 1960, ça a continué. J'ai, mais ça fait maintenant exactement trente ans, un article dont le titre : Le maître est resté maître, l'esclave est devenu un élève.
C'est-à-dire, à l'époque de la traite, le maître, c'était un Blanc, l'esclave, c'était un Noir. Pendant l'ère coloniale, bon le chef, le patron, dans tous les domaines, que ça soit politique, économique, social, etc.
C'était des Blancs, et les subordonnés, c'étaient les travailleurs et les cultivateurs noirs. Et après l'indépendance, cette mentalité s'est poursuivie.
C'est-à-dire, bon voilà, on partait toujours du fait que les Européens avaient à apprendre aux Africains à se développer et à développer leur société.
Donc ça continue. Et c'est pour ça que moi, je dis depuis un certain temps, et les gens considèrent ça comme une forme de radicalité, mais ce n'est pas ça.
Mais il faut chercher la vérité. Et la vérité est brutale. La vérité est violente depuis plusieurs siècles, pour les Africains.
Vous faites ce rappel parce que vous estimez qu'il y a une forme de whitewashing, qu'on essaie de ne pas voir cette brutalité, cette violence-
C'est ça, c'est ça. J'étais membre, enfin j'étais expert pour cette commission parlementaire qui allait à la recherche des vérités de la colonisation belge. J'ai dit ça,
j'ai répété cela à plusieurs reprises. Donc c'est vraiment cette involonté, pour ainsi dire, ce refus pour la plupart des anciennes puissances coloniales de reconnaître leurs méfaits et leurs crimes, qu'ils ont perpétré durant l'ère coloniale.
Et donc moi, je ne veux pas qu'on discute, il faut réparer cela, il faut autant de millions ou de milliards, mais il faut que, en ce qui concerne le Congo, mais aussi le Rwanda, Burundi, que les Belges soient conscients que
les Congolais ne peuvent pas pardonner ces crimes-là, ces méfaits-là aussi longtemps que les Belges ne reconnaissent pas tout cela.
C'est la première étape.
C'est la première étape. Et je sais que d'autres pays ont déjà fait ça. L'Allemagne a fait ça pour la Namibie, le massacre, le génocide des Hereros en 1905.
Les Anglais ont fait ça pour, disons, la révolte des Mau Mau, qui au Kenya, à partir de 1955, jusqu'en 1960, 62, ils ont reconnu cela.
Ils ont reconnu tous ces excès, toutes ces atrocités. Parce que mine de rien, dans la révolte de Kikuyu au Kenya, ils ont tué presque septante mille Kenyans.
Septante mille. Ils ont interné presque cent soixante mille Kenyans dans des camps de relégation. Ils ont reconnu cela et pour le Kenya, c'était bon.
On peut toujours discuter pour, bon voilà,
les Anglais, si je ne me trompe pas, ont payé vingt-trois virgule cinq millions d'euros, qu'ils ont versés à l'État, non à l'État kenyan,
mais à tous ceux, les cinq mille personnes qui ont introduit un dossier, là, je ne sais pas auprès de quel tribunal.
Donc c'est normal si les Africains ne vont jamais oublier cela, mais ils peuvent pardonner.
Mais ça doit commencer ici, dans la conscience des Européens de reconnaître qu'ils ont mal fait, que des millions et des millions d'Africains ont été des victimes de leur politique coloniale.
Oui, oui puisqu'on a pu voir à plusieurs occasions des politiciens s'excuser, mais effectivement, dans la conscience collective chez les Belges, ça reste un trou noir, entre guillemets, une absence, une,
voilà, comme je le disais tout à l'heure, on nous apprend pas ça à l'école.
Oui, mais même au niveau, disons, au niveau de l'establishment, c'est difficile, c'est archi difficile.
Ils peinent à reconnaître cela. Vraiment, ils peinent. Hein. Donc encore une fois, c'est mon témoignage, hein, dans cette commission parlementaire.
Hein, donc ils traînent et ils croient que par des petits gestes de bienveillance, hein, que les Congolais vont, hein.
C'est pour cela que moi, quand il y a autant d'années le roi Philippe s'est rendu au Congo, qu'il a parlé.
Donc il faut tourner la page. Non. L'histoire, on ne peut pas tourner la page. Hein, on peut pas cacher. The hidden history, hein, on ne peut pas accepter cela.
Et il est, d'aller là avec un masque-là de je ne sais pas quel chef congolais du Sankuru. Hein, un geste.
Bon voilà, on va maintenant discuter de la restitution des choses. Mais c'est quoi ça ?
On ne peut pas, on peut pas accepter cela. Ce n'est pas pour un seul masque que nous allons maintenant dire : c'est fini.
Hein, on n'en parle plus. Non, non, non, non. C'est pour cela, à mon avis, hein, donc ces derniers temps, j'ai été en septembre, en octobre et puis dernièrement au Congo pour participer à des séminaires et à des colloques.
J'ai à chaque fois utilisé l'expression : il faut que l'on renverse la table. Vraiment renverser la table. La table, hein, pleine, hein, de livres, d'histoire écrits par les Belges de l'époque coloniale et de l'époque postcoloniale.
Je ne suis pas biblioclaste, comme on dit, hein, donc je ne veux pas qu'on brûle tout, tout ça. Non, non, non, non, mais il faut renverser la table.
Hein, et on doit, et c'est ça la tâche, la tâche des Congolais, réécrire ça, hein, et donner. C'est un exercice que les historiens ont dû faire ces dernières décennies.
Hein. La place de la femme dans l'histoire, la place des travailleurs en tout ça. Parce que c'était toujours, on retient toujours les noms des politiciens, premiers ministres, etc.
Des évêques, des archevêques, etc. Des grands CEO. Donc de ces-- non, non. On a déjà fait cet exercice-là et on doit faire le même exercice pour ce qui concerne, hein, en ce qui concerne donc l'histoire coloniale.
Renverser la table. Et maintenant, on va, hein, les expériences des victimes de la colonisation. Et moi, je ne suis pas quelqu'un qui veut qu'à tout prix les Congolais se victimisent.
Non, mais ils ont été victimes, hein, d'un système horrible qui était le système colonial. Donc, il faut maintenant qu'on écoute, hein, et qu'on essaye de connaître l'effet de leurs expériences coloniales.
C'est vraiment, c'est urgent.
Mh. Mh. Et donc cette notion de renverser la table vient aussi du fait que,
voilà, c'était assez évident, par exemple, quand on voyait les discours qui avaient lieu le jour, donc, de la déclaration d'indépendance du Congo, donc le 30 juin 1960.
Il y avait le discours du roi Baudouin. Il y avait le discours de, si je ne m'abuse, de-
Patrice Lumumba.
Et donc le discours du roi Baudouin était surtout là pour rappeler, entre guillemets, les bienfaits, les routes,
toutes les, tous les apports des Blancs et tout ce que le pays, tout ce en quoi le pays avait bénéficié de l'arrivée de la Belgique.
Et à l'inverse, celui de Patrice Lumumba était plutôt là pour rappeler la violence et la domination.
Mh.
Et donc y a, y a globalement, quand on regarde l'histoire, donc, de la période coloniale du Congo,
ce double regard, cette double lecture, cette envie pour certains de lire ça comme étant un bienfait, le Congo en aurait grandement bénéficié.
C'est grâce à la Belgique, ils devraient dire merci, hein, c'est presque ça.
Oui, oui, oui, la gratitude-
Voilà.
C'est le terme que les coloniaux et les missionnaires ont utilisé au-delà de 1960.
Mh. Oui, c'est ça. On va revenir un peu plus tard, sans doute, sur
ce double regard, hein, sur cette gratitude que j'évoquais il y a un instant, notamment dans le contexte de la commission parlementaire que vous avez évoquée tout à l'heure.
Mais avant ça, peut-être revenir sur un aspect qu'on a très rapidement évoqué, qui est donc le fameux caoutchouc rouge.
Mh.
Donc c'est, voilà, cette exploitation violente du peuple congolais qui était forcé, comme je disais, violemment, de récolter le caoutchouc de l'hévéa, voilà, un peu partout au Congo.
Tâche impopulaire, désagréable et le sang qui coule puisque y avait pas d'incentive économique ou de récompense, quoi que ce soit.
C'était juste la coercition, c'était juste la menace de violence raciste. Pour rappeler, puisque comme je le disais, la plupart des gens, malheureusement, n'ont pas entendu ça à l'école.
Pour rappeler un petit peu quelle était l'étendue de ces violences, combien de temps ça a duré, combien de personnes est-ce que ça a touché ?
Puisque on, voilà, on va aborder ça peut-être juste après, mais parfois, on parle de génocide. On va discuter de si c'est pertinent ou pas.
Mais donc l'étendue de ces violences dans ton, sur la durée et sur le nombre de personnes concernées.
Oui, mais écoutez, ça a commencé tout d'abord par les récoltes d'ivoire. Hein. Soudainement, c'est fini et ça commence donc avec le caoutchouc.
Que l'on n'oublie pas, hein. On peut pas perdre de vue que c'était une taxation, c'était des impôts. Hein. On imposait cela aux Congolais.
Et on sait très bien, parce que bon, voilà combien de tonnes de caoutchouc sont arrivées à Anvers. On sait ça exactement.
Hein. Dans un de mes livres, j'ai donné des chiffres, hein, parce que c'est connu. À Anvers, quand le bateau, le navire revenait du Congo, c'était avec des tonnes et des tonnes.
Et c'était bien connu, hein, autant pour l'État et Léopold II, autant pour la bière, autant pour d'autres sociétés anversoises, etc.
C'était connu, hein. Les bénéfices, hein, les gros bénéfices faits par, disons, en général, les Belges, c'est connu. Et alors, moi, je pose aux Belges, hein,
combien d'écoles, hein, parce que ils parlaient aussi beaucoup de cette mission civilisatrice.
Combien d'écoles a-t-il fait construire au Congo ? De 1885 jusqu'en 1908. Combien ? Hein. Même pas cinq.
Mh.
Même pas cinq. Et alors, il utilisait les quelques congrégations missionnaires qui étaient là pour que eux, hein, pour que elles, hein, donnent des enseignements.
C'était moitié-moitié, religion, catéchèse, etc. Et puis, parce qu'on était convaincus de cela, le Noir, il est, en fait, il faut apprendre aux Noirs de travailler.
Hein, hein. Donc c'était un peu ça. Et donc des officiers qui venaient donc donner des cours militaires, des instructions militaires à ces gens-là.
Même pas cinq. On oublie, hein, dans mon dernier livre, donc, que j'ai publié en avril 2023,
j'ai prouvé que le médecin que Léopold II envoyait au Congo, c'était des médecins militaires qui devaient accompagner la force publique, donc l'armée coloniale, lors des expéditions, hein, partout au Congo.
Hein, donc, c'est, hein. Et puis, dans certains centres, c'était et pour, disons, les officiers, les Blancs de l'administration et leurs auxiliaires.
Mais pour la population ou les populations congolaises, aucun médecin a été envoyé au Congo. Ça a commencé après l'annexion.
Là, la Belgique a décidé : donc, nous devons aussi nous occuper de la santé des populations.
Et on s'étonne que les maladies qui ont décimé, pour ainsi dire, les populations congolaises, hein, donc à partir de 1897, c'était la maladie de sommeil.
Et on s'étonne que les Noirs considéraient ça comme une maladie blanche, c'est-à-dire une maladie introduite par les Blancs.
Hein, parce que pour la plupart d'entre eux, c'était inconnu. Et donc, la maladie de sommeil, qu'est-ce que l'on doit faire ?
C'est garder les gens, les villageois dans leur village. Plus de communication, plus de mobilité-
Une quarantaine.
Une sorte de quarantaine. Et pour l'État, ce n'était pas possible. Parce qu'il fallait envoyer des militaires à gauche et à droite là où il y avait des révoltes, etc.
Donc la mobilité, disons, la mobilité coloniale a augmenté les risques, enfin, disons, l'extension de ces maladies-là. Et les gens disaient : « Ça, c'est les Blancs.
C'est les Blancs ». Hein. Et donc ce n'est qu'à partir de 1908 que la Belgique, hein-
A changé son paradigme pour-
A changé-
Se préoccuper davantage-
Se préoccuper. Et donc il fallait investir en ça parce qu'il fallait aussi avoir des Congolais en bonne santé pour travailler dans les mines, travailler dans les plantations, etc.
Donc ça ne pouvait pas continuer comme ça. Donc-
Mais vous, vous me parlez de la maladie de sommeil-
Oui
Donc suite à ma question donc sur le caoutchouc rouge.
Oui.
Donc c'est quoi ? Ce serait principalement des questions de maladies qui ont amené à tous ces décès ou ?
Non, non, non, non, non, non, non.
Parce que c'est-
C'est que quand on tient compte, hein, des conditions-
Mmm-hmm
Dans lesquelles les populations, les villageois devaient récolter cela, cela a-
Obligé la coercition, obligé-
Obligé les gens. Donc, on avait moins de temps pour ses propres récoltes de cassave, donc de manioc, etc., de maïs, etc.
Parce que après un certain temps, il fallait-- et donc c'était autant de kilos par mois. Et donc il fallait parfois trois quarts du mois passés dans les forêts, hein, pour trouver, hein, pour récolter.
Donc les hommes étaient partis et j'ai publié une photo. Dans beaucoup de villages, on était obligé aussi de faire accompagner les hommes adultes par des enfants.
Donc le travail d'enfant, c'est ça la colonisation hein. Des petits de dix ans, douze ans, etc. Et alors on explique : « Oui, mais le Noir, physiquement, il est plus vite mûr ou mature, etc. »
Des fois, on manipule la science pour justifier-
Oui, oui, oui, pour justifier tout cela. Et donc c'est ça. Encore une fois, hein, donc là, je signe, je persiste, il faut non seulement renverser la table, mais lutter contre tous ces mensonges, préjugés, etc.
qui ont eu des effets désastreux sur les sociétés locales. Hein. Donc, on doit accepter cela, hein. Et donc on doit écrire cela.
Ça, c'est bien de dire : « Bon, on a bâti un hôpital là-bas en 1800, ou en 1907 et puis l'autre.
» Non, non. Hein. Il y a ce problème que les récoltes, hein, donc le caoutchouc, hein, mais vraiment, hein, donc cette imposition qui a eu des longues conséquences pour rien, hein, que autour de cela, il y avait des maladies.
C'était une surexploitation de l'homme congolais. Et il ne faut pas dire que c'était dans certaines régions. Non.
Partout, hein, que ça soit dans le Bas-Congo, que ça soit dans l'Ituri ou dans l'est du Congo, parce que normalement, on parle toujours, hein, donc de ces récoltes dans l'Équateur et puis
dans le lac Moïse-Dombe, l'ancien lac Léopold II.
Non, ça a été partout. Partout, partout, partout. Que l'on reconnaisse ça. Hein. Donc les documents sont là.
Je reviens avec ma question. Donc si on voulait chiffrer un petit peu pour donner une idée aux personnes qui nous écoutent-
Oui
L'étendue de cette, de ces violences et l'étendue de ces-
Oui, oui, c'est difficile à dire parce que, à ce moment-là, l'administration s'occupait plutôt donc des impôts que de recensement d'hommes ou autant de femmes.
Et donc, ça, on-- d'ailleurs, on ne savait pas combien de Congolais vivaient sur ce territoire gigantesque, mais on sait qu'il y a eu beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup de morts.
Hein. Et pour moi, ce n'est pas une question de ce génocide ou pas. Je dis tout simplement que les conséquences de ce régime, hein, ont été énormes, énormément négatives pour les populations locales.
Donc si je me permets d'insister. Donc énorme, on parle de quoi ? De dizaines de millions ? On parle de-
On sait même pas. Moi, personnellement, je ne crois pas qu'il y avait des dizaines de millions d'habitants au centre de l'Afrique.
Ça, je n'ose pas, je n'ose pas dire.
Beaucoup de débats.
Oui, il y a beaucoup de débats sur-
Je pose cette question parce que régulièrement, on place le roi Léopold II dans les personnes les plus sanguinaires de l'histoire.
C'est pour ça que je pose cette question.
Oui, mais moi, je comprends la question, hein, mais on ne dispose pas de chiffres exacts.
D'accord.
Hein, impossible. Impossible. Parce que parfois, hein, moi, je--
un exemple. Hein. Après la commission Lumumba, il y a plus de vingt ans, hein, on a décidé de dire une petite place là à Matongé, hein, place Lumumba
Oui, mais Lumumba, c'était trois personnes qui ont été tuées avec Okito et Mpolo.
Mais encore une fois, dans mes livres, il y a, par exemple, toutes ces expéditions partout au Congo où on a massacré des gens.
Hein, je donne un exemple, hein, au nord, dans l'Ubélé, chez les Ababwas, qui, en 1901, 1902, commencent à résister au régime colonial.
C'est la révolte, hein, sous la direction de quelqu'un, Nzapéré. Des expéditions punitives et militaires punitives ont été organisées.
Et là, le chef de l'expédition, hein, Chaltin, hein, il écrit : « Bon voilà, un tel jour, on a maté la révolte. En un jour, on a tué quatre cents personnes.
» Quatre cents. Quatre cents.
C'est bien au-delà des victimes d'attentats terroristes-
Oui, oui, oui, oui
...aujourd'hui en Europe.
Oui, oui. Oui, oui. Oui, oui. Oui, oui. Et alors, on se plaint quand le- et à juste titre, quand les Allemands dans un village ont exécuté dix ou vingt ou trente personnes.
Mais ils ont fait exactement la même chose, hein, pour garder, pour conserver le pouvoir, pour dominer les populations congolaises.
Bon écoutez, je n'invente rien.
Ça donne en tout cas une idée de la considération que-
C'est ça
...l'occupant donnait aux Congolais.
Oui, écoutez, c'est toujours comme ça, hein. Donc les occupants essaient toujours de faire croire que c'est pour le meilleur des populations locales, hein, l'ordre colonial.
Parce que les Congolais, c'est le désordre, c'est l'indiscipline, etc. Ce n'est que eux qui peuvent, hein, imposer l'ordre colonial.
Mais à quel prix ? Ça, on oublie parfois de dire, hein. Et donc, le cas de Nzapéré, là, chez les Ababwas, ce n'est pas un cas rare.
Oui. Si à partir de là, on avance, on fait un petit saut en avant dans l'histoire et qu'on arrive dans les années quarante, Deuxième Guerre mondiale, que se passe-t-il vis-à-vis des Congolais ?
Est-ce que les Congolais sont employés comme force militaire, comme force de combat ?
Ah oui, oui, oui. Mais je vais vous confier une chose. Quand la Belgique est sortie sans un franc de dette à la fin de la Deuxième Guerre mondiale, c'est grâce à qui ?
C'est grâce au Congo. C'est grâce aux Congolais, que l'on n'oublie pas ça. Hein, c'est les Belges qui ont vendu l'uranium, hein, de Shinkolobwe aux Américains pour-
Le projet Manhattan.
Oui, fabriquer les bombes atomiques là, qu'ils ont droppées sur le Japon, Nagasaki et Hiroshima.
Hein, c'est grâce à ça. Ils ont vendu, hein, parce qu'ils considéraient ça comme leur appartenant.
Hein. Et donc, pour le plan Maréchal, c'était facile parce que les Français qui n'avaient pas eu cette occasion-là, ils avaient besoin de l'aide des Américains, etc.
Et il y a eu, après la Deuxième Guerre mondiale, la construction de la route nationale de Matadi à Léopoldville, donc l'actuelle Kinshasa.
C'est les Américains qui ont financé cela pour remercier les Congolais. Ils se sont occupés de cela parce qu'ils savaient, on donne cet argent aux Belges, ils savaient-
Le roi Léopold, parfois, faisait des emprunts au nom du Congo et finalement-
Oui
...on avait l'argent pour faire des projets urbanistiques en Belgique.
Donc c'est ça, hein. L'histoire a ses vérités et ses vérités ont leurs droits. Il faut le dire. Hein, donc,
encore une fois, hein, l'historien n'a pas à jouer au chevalier blanc ou je ne sais pas quoi, hein, mais on cherche les vérités, hein, de manière objective.
On essaie de mieux connaître les faits, de collectionner, de ramasser des faits et de les interpréter. Et pas dans le souci de donner et d'embellir l'image de la Belgique, etc.
Ou-- non, non, non, non, non, ce n'est pas ça. Hein. Aussi longtemps, hein, et c'est pour ça que je dis ça, c'est la première fois, moi, j'aurai septante ans d'ici quelques semaines.
Ça fait plus de cinquante ans que je suis dans le métier d'historien et je dois dire,
je sens ça. Même le fait que je suis quelqu'un du passé et un peu du présent, mes étudiants sont des gens de l'avenir, mais je dois leur dire que la domination occidentale, c'est fini.
Il faut le rappeler.
La domination occidentale, c'est fini. Donc, les Européens
ont vraiment la lourde tâche de s'adapter à la nouvelle situation que, hein-- moi, je ne dis pas les Chinois, les Russes, etc., les Turcs, les Indiens, etc.
Mais c'est fini. C'est fini, ce temps-là. Après cinq ou six siècles de domination, c'est fini. Ce sont des-- ce qui se passe là en Ukraine ou, disons, au Moyen-Orient, etc.
Et même pour le Tibet. Mais c'est fini, le temps que les Européens, hein, avec moins de dix pour cent de la population mondiale possédaient nonante pour cent des richesses mondiales.
C'est fini. On doit s'adapter à ça pour bien survivre. On doit comprendre cela. Je vois ça lors de mes voyages au Congo.
C'est des ra-- le Congo, c'est des rapports avec des Turcs, avec des Indiens, avec les Chinois qui n'ont pas un passé colonial au Congo, hein.
Ils n'ont pas du tout ça. Et donc c'est eux-- en partie, il y a de l'argent. Ce sont des pays émergents comme on les appelle.
Donc ça change beaucoup. Donc tout ce qui est le développement et la coopération, c'est rien du tout par rapport à ce que les Chinois peuvent faire, les Turcs peuvent faire ou les Brésiliens dans ces pays-là.
On doit s'adapter à ça. On doit tout d'abord comprendre cela. C'est fini.
On voit ça avec claquement de doigts, le-- que ça soit de-- enfin, peut-être pas de Gaulle, mais Mitterrand et les autres, jusqu'à Sarkozy pouvaient faire tomber un gouvernement, là, en Afrique de l'Ouest.
Maintenant, ils ont été chassés. Mali, Burkina Faso et dernièrement, le Sénégal, le nouveau président a dit quoi ? Stop la présence militaire de la France au Sénégal.
C'est fini. C'est fini. Donc le reste du monde, parce que pour les Occidentaux, c'était le reste du monde, hein, n'accepte plus ça.
Juste pour revenir donc à ma question qui était donc vis-à-vis de l'implication du Congo dans la Deuxième Guerre mondiale.
Donc, on parlait de l'uranium, par exemple, mais vraiment pour ce qui est de l'action militaire, des soldats congolais qui étaient ramenés en Europe.
Voilà, quelle proportion-
Pas en Europe, donc Nigéria, Éthiopie, Moyen-Orient jusque Birmanie, etc. Mais donc, la Belgique a utilisé les soldats congolais pour lutter contre les Allemands et les Japonais, les Italiens.
On oublie tout cela.
Ce n'est pas sérieux, ça. Même lors de la Première Guerre mondiale, hein, c'est grâce aux militaires congolais qu'ils ont connu leur première victoire militaire,
hein, belge, parce que ces soldats congolais étaient considérés comme des soldats belges.
Donc au Cameroun. Et puis, disons, l'occupation, hein, la conquête du Rwanda-Urundi et presque la moitié de la Tanzanie, c'était l'œuvre de nos militaires pendant la Première Guerre mondiale.
Mais parbleu, il y a plus de Congolais qui ont perdu leur vie dans cette Première Guerre mondiale que de Belges. Et puis, quand on a fêté le centenaire de la Première Guerre mondiale, c'était en 2014, qu'est-ce qu'on a vu ?
Plus d'une centaine de livres sur les Belges et cette Première Guerre mondiale, moindre résistance dans un petit village là, Ramskapelle ou je ne sais pas quoi.
Donc des dizaines et des dizaines de livres ont été consacrés à cela. Mais sur, disons, les efforts militaires des Congolais, combien ?
On a organisé un colloque à Kinshasa et on a publié un livre là chez L'Harmattan sur ça. Mais pour le reste, donc les gens ne s'intéressent plus à ça.
C'est : qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en Belgique pendant ces deux guerres-là ? Mais pas que les-- c'est grâce aux Congolais qu'ils ont...
Encore une fois, il faut renverser la table. Il ne faut pas du tout brûler ces livres-là, mais il faut mettre sur la table maintenant des livres qui parlent effectivement donc de l'État indépendant du Congo, de ce qui s'est passé là-bas.
Et on constate, à l'heure actuelle, il y a une nouvelle tendance. Tendance, c'est, bon voilà, décoloniser les espaces publics, etc.
Le monument de Storms, là, à Ixelles, a été enlevé, bon, etc. Mais on oublie qu'au Congo, on a fait cet exercice-là déjà dans les années 1970.
Tous ces monuments coloniaux là-bas ont disparu de l'espace public. Disparu. Maintenant, on essaye de les remplacer par des Congolais qui ont une certaine signification pour, hein.
Donc bien sûr, c'est toujours les icônes, des figures emblématiques comme Lumumba ou Kabila ou Kasa-Vubu, etc. Mais donc, cinquante ans plus tard, on croit, bon voilà, on fait maintenant du bien.
Mais non, c'est-- les historiens belges peuvent s'amuser avec ça. On n'entre plus dans cette discussion-là.
Notre discussion, notre débat se porte sur qu'est-ce qui s'est passé au Congo ? Les expériences des Congolais.
Et donc cet emploi, donc, des forces congolaises pour mener des guerres de Blancs-
Oui, oui, oui, oui, c'est des guerres de Blancs
...l'Allemagne, le Japon, etc.
J'ai pu lire, j'ai pu comprendre que c'était en partie ça qui avait joué pour faire que les vétérans congolais avaient alors commencé à ressentir une forme de,
de fatigue, une prise de conscience qu'ils sont une nation à part et qu'ils ne sont pas vraiment, voilà, aussi belges que les Blancs, quoi, pour dire ça comme ça, et que,
voilà, que c'est peut-être les premières graines d'un mouvement nationaliste.
Est-ce que c'est juste de dire ça ?
Après chaque guerre, on a eu ces mouvements, on a connu ces mouvements nationalistes. Après, je commence avec la Première Guerre mondiale.
Après la Première Guerre mondiale, où les Congolais ont dû faire des efforts sérieux, hein, en hommes, hein, en militaires.
Mais aussi, c'était de nouveau le caoutchouc, parce qu'on avait besoin de ça pour des tentes, des trucs comme ça. Et pour les Belges, la guerre finie, on reprend la politique d'avant la guerre.
Mais les simples Congolais disaient : Mais écoutez, on-- ça fait maintenant autant de décennies qu'on paye pour le roi Albert, pour le roi Léopold, etc.
Et vous venez de nouveau, hein, réclamer des impôts, là. Hein, donc on voit le, ce sentiment de mécontentement.
Hein. Donc on ne voyait pas évoluer la situation, hein, dans la bonne direction. C'est-à-dire, bien sûr, on voulait un peu plus d'enseignement, des écoles, etc.
Mais de nouveau avec des taxes ici, des taxes là-bas, etc. Donc c'était un mécontentement. Et on a connu, on a eu la même situation après la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Hein. Et il faut dire que lors de la Première Guerre mondiale, c'était la première génération des Congolais qui avaient été éduqués dans leur village, hein, donc qui connaissaient bien les traditions, les coutumes, etc.
Hein, grâce à leurs parents, là, dans les villages et qui, à côté de cela, fréquentaient les écoles missionnaires. Donc c'étaient des gens à double éducation, hein, traditionnelle et moderne.
Après la Seconde Guerre mondiale,
c'est à peu près la même chose. Là, on a pour la première fois, pas des gens qui avaient fréquenté des écoles missionnaires, c'est-à-dire des écoles primaires,
mais des gens qui avaient quand même fait des études un peu plus sérieuses, qui commençaient déjà
à bien, enfin réfléchir, ça, ils ont toujours fait, mais prendre, réfléchir sur : Mais écoutez,
les Blancs, hein, même si on a étudié, on reste toujours le citoyen de second rang.
C'est ça. Hein. Et donc, et c'était dans la législation coloniale, un militaire congolais ne pouvait pas devenir sous-officier, officier.
C'est, c'est quoi ça ? Hein. Et n'importe qui-
Hein.
Hein, blanc,
c'était tout de suite officier. C'était, hein, donc même s'il ne savait pas où situer le Congo, mais, hein,
en provenance de la Belgique, étant blanc, étant européen, il avait déjà, hein, donc il pouvait commander les Noirs.
Et à ce moment-
Ça provoquait des frictions.
À l'issue des conflits, inversement, les Noirs ne recevaient pas de pension militaire, ne recevaient pas de promotion à proprement parler.
Au mieux, c'était, on les félicitait pour leur courage, éventuellement.
Je-- encore une fois, je vous ai dit ma radicalité. Hein, c'est scandaleux. Mais vraiment scandaleux ce que les Belges ont fait avec nos vétérans militaires.
C'est scandaleux. Je ne vais pas consacrer plus de mots à ça, mais c'est tout simplement, hein-
Je comprends.
C'est un scandale.
C'est un scandale. Et donc on-- que la diplomatie et tout ce qui est politique continue à dire : Oui, oui, oui, mais bon, voilà.
Non, qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait pour eux ? Rien du tout.
Donc tout ça a accéléré donc, comme on disait, un sentiment nationaliste et un-
Ben un nationa-, moi, je dirais un sentiment nationaliste, mais plutôt un sentiment anti-Blanc.
Ok.
Oui. Vraiment anti-Blanc. Et eux vont dire que c'est de la xénophobie, mais le régime colonial est déjà basé sur la xénophobie.
Qui étaient les xénophobes à ce moment-là ? C'étaient eux. Hein, c'étaient eux qui se sentaient supérieurs aux Noirs.
Du ressentiment contre une politique raciste, ce n'est pas, voilà, ce que j'appellerais de la xénophobie.
Non.
Et donc on s'approche alors donc de 1960, l'indépendance du Congo, jusque, je pense, 1956. Alors, pour être tout à fait transparent, 1956, c'est l'année de naissance de ma maman qui est née au Congo.
Ah !
Donc voilà, donc c'est à ce moment-là que je-
Elle n'a que-
J'arrive dans l'histoire.
Une année de moins que moi.
Voilà. Voilà. Et mais donc déjà, encore à ce moment-là, on ne parlait pas à proprement parler, on n'était pas en train de discuter d'une politique d'indépendance pour le Congo.
Et tout commence à s'accélérer à partir de 57, 58, 59, 1960. Qu'est-ce qui déclenche tout ça ?
Écoutez, quand, hein, 1955, quand le roi Baudouin a fait, comment, hein, son entrée solennelle, là, à Kinshasa.
Donc, il était accompagné de dizaines et de dizaines de journalistes. Et un des journalistes, hein, un Flamand, Louis de Lintac, qu'est-ce qu'il disait ?
Écoutez, il parlait avec les Congolais et les Congolais disaient tout simplement : Oui, c'est bien, hein, mais vous allez voir, même dans la cité ou dans les cités où le roi, hein, doit passer, on a asphalté les routes.
Pour le reste, hein, rien, nada. Hein. Donc les gens vivaient encore dans le noir. Hein, donc ils avaient, il y avait donc des centrales hydroélectriques, mais les Belges, hein,
utilisaient ça pour les quartiers blancs et un peu commercial et industriel de Kinshasa, mais le reste, on vendait ça à Congo, hein, Brazzaville.
Et les Noirs disaient ça : Mais écoutez, hein, pourquoi pas, hein, vous vendez ça. Au lieu de nous donner de l'électricité, vous préférez faire de l'argent de ça et de vendre ça.
C'est ça un peu. Et donc le roi, quand il a visité, quand il a vu le Congo, hein, bah tout avait été bien arrangé, etc.
C'était le nouveau roi Baudouin, alors.
C'était le nouveau en 1955.
Suite à l'abdication de son père.
Oui, oui. Oui, oui. Et donc c'est un peu ça. C'est-- cela signifie que qu'est-ce qu'on a montré au roi
Tout ce qui était beau, tout ce qui était propre, et cetera, hein, tout ce que effectivement les Blancs avaient-- les Belges avaient fait, mais pas toujours, hein, au bénéfice des indigènes, comme on dit.
C'est le cas de le dire, ouais.
Ouais. Et les gens, hein, donc, voyaient cela, hein, faisaient des réflexions sur ça. Il faut quand même pas dire que ceux qui disaient ça aux journalistes belges, qu'ils étaient contents de la colonisation belge.
Mh.
Hein ? Non, non, non. C'était prati-- hein, l'apartheid, hein. Là, des magasins pour des Blancs et des magasins pour les autres.
Ouais.
C'était ça les réalités coloniales.
Des villas et des hôpitaux spacieux pour les Blancs-
Oui, oui, oui
...très serrés, très condensés-
Oui
...mal gérés pour les Noirs.
Oui. Donc c'est ça. Et en plus, hein, on a commencé petit à petit à impliquer quelques Noirs dans des comités provinciaux, et cetera.
Et ce que l'on oublie, c'est que le musée de Tervuren, l'Institut tropical d'Anvers, et cetera, et d'autres instituts tropicaux, c'était sur le budget de la colonie.
C'était payé par les Congolais.
Mh.
Mais, hein, quand ils ont découvert ça, ils ont fait : « C'est scandaleux, ça. » Hein ? C'est scandaleux. Et pour moi, hein, c'est les émeutes du 4 janvier 1959 qui ont en fait sonné la fin de la colonisation belge.
Le 4 janvier 19-, hein, à Kinshasa, à Léopoldville d'ailleurs. Et puis cela s'est étendu comme un feu de brousse dans d'autres villes congolaises, et cetera.
Lors de ma dernière visite au Congo avec des historiens, mais aussi avec des hommes politiques, je leur dis : « Écoutez, à partir du 4 janvier 1959, c'était l'insurrection. »
Mh.
Et c'était donc la fin de la colonisation.
Et cette insurrection, comment ça se fait que la Belgique n'a pas souhaité la mater, l'écraser ?
Si, si, ils ont fait, ils ont fait.
OK.
Mais jamais d'enquête, hein, combien de Congolais ont été tués, hein, par la force publique et par les...
Non, non, ça jamais.
Non.
Ça jamais. Hein. On ne connaît même pas le nombre exact des morts. Hein. Mais c'était fini. Et donc, hein, lentement mais sûrement, on commence à négocier l'indépendance.
Et, en janvier, février 1960, il est décidé, hein, en fait, par les Belges, d'octroyer l'indépendance, la souveraineté, aux Congolais le 30 juin 1960.
Moi, je dis aux Congolais : « Il faut plus fêter ça. » Une indépendance octroyée, hein, dans le sens, on montre, oui, voilà, nous sommes, on comprend et on vous donne l'indépendance.
Voilà. Non. Ce que nous devons fêter, c'est ce 4 janvier 1959. Ce jour-là a commencé la marche vers notre indépendance et vers notre souveraineté.
Hein. Donc, encore une fois, renverser la table, hein. Octroyée par les Belges. Non, nous, notre rôle en tout cela. Le 4 janvier 1959.
Et bien sûr, on sait pas au Congo quand je dis ça, mais encore une fois, c'est plus de cinquante ans, donc, dans ce métier.
Après des réflex-- mûres réflexions, voilà, ce que je propose, c'est tout simplement changer de date.
Mh.
Et dire : « Voilà la date de notre indépendance. Nous avons montré notre volonté d'être libres et souverains à partir de ce moment-là.
» Et ils ont tué des centaines et des centaines de Congolais.
Mh.
Hein, donc, il faut dire ça aux Belges, parce que maintenant, hein, ou le 30 juin, ça se résume toujours au, disons, aux exposés, enfin, au truc là de Lumumba et du roi Baudouin.
Non, non, non, non, non, non. Non. C'est plus d'une année, hein, une année et demie avant cela que ça a commencé. On doit, hein, c'est, ça, c'est l'histoire coloniale ou l'histoire congolaise revisitée, comme on dit.
Alors, à partir de cette date-là, donc, s'ensuit donc toute une période de guerre froide, les Soviétiques s'impliquent, l'assassinat donc de Patrice Lumumba.
Énormément de complexité. On va malheureusement pas avoir le temps de démêler tout ça. Il faudrait une dizaine-
Quelle complexité ?
Bah, c'est-à-dire qu'il y a les Américains, les Nations Unies, il y a les Soviétiques, il y a la Belgique, il y a les Congolais. C'est beaucoup de-
Mais, mais, mais-
...beaucoup de participants, oui
...mais soyons clairs, le pays est indépendant, hein, octroyé, une indépendance octroyée le 30 juin 1960. Les Belges n'avaient plus rien à voir dans la politique congolaise, hein.
Que ça soit clair une bonne fois pour toutes. Et ils ont continué-
Oui
...à se mêler de tout cela et, de dire-
C'est une présence militaire qui avait été négociée comme étant-- il devait avoir l'aval de Lumumba, mais il s'est donné-
Le Katanga, tout. Hein, ce sont des sacrés manipulateurs, hein. Hein. Encore une fois, c'est scandaleux. Hein, donc, il a été conduit à la mort grâce à l'appui et à la volonté des Belges.
Oui. Oui, donc on restait dans ce paradigme du, voilà, ce que vous disiez, le maître blanc, c'est-à-dire le, une logique raciste où on accorde vraiment assez peu d'importance à la justice.
C'est simple, les Belges n'avaient plus rien à voir avec la politique ni intérieure ni extérieure du Congo.
Mh.
Mais c'est de nouveau dans cet esprit-là de dominer, de vouloir contrôler les richesses de ce pays-là. Hein ? C'est, est-ce que c'est ça ? Il faut—
Oui, d'ailleurs, le roi Baudouin, au moment où il fait son discours, a en tête l'idée de jouer un rôle important dans la suite des événements, de rester un acteur important dans le nouveau Congo.
Oui, mais moi, je dis toujours, hein : il faut en vouloir aux conseillers du roi.
Mh.
Parce que son speech, fait par ses conseillers, contresigné par le Premier ministre, et cetera. On dit toujours Baudouin, Baudouin, Baudouin.
Mais c'est aussi Gaston Eyskens, hein—
Mh.
Qui a accepté cela. Ses conseillers qui ont. Ce n'est pas le roi qui a rédigé. C'est ça. Et donc—
Je ne pointe pas singulièrement le roi, mais c'est collectivement—
C'est collectivement.
Donc, on restait dans ce logiciel—
Oui, oui.
...de dominant.
C'est ça.
Je vais accélérer un petit peu. Donc, on—
Ah bon, oui.
On parlait de—
Tout à l'heure, j'évoquais donc cette commission spéciale, cette commission parlementaire chargée de
se pencher sur l'État indépendant du Congo et sur le passé colonial de la Belgique au Congo, au Rwanda et au Burundi aussi par ailleurs, et les enseignements qu'on pouvait, et qu'il convenait de tirer de tout ça.
Donc, c'était en décembre 2022, après avoir auditionné plus de, enfin, environ trois cents experts et témoins,
les membres de la Commission Passé colonial ont constaté apparemment, visiblement, une incapacité à se mettre d'accord vis-à-vis des conclusions à tirer et des recommandations à formuler au gouvernement.
Le rapport n'a pas pu être publié. Finalement, il y a eu une fuite dans la presse, hein, c'était sur le site de la RTBF.
On pouvait lire ce rapport.
Qu'est-ce que ça illustre ? Qu'est-ce que ça dit, le fait que encore dans l'histoire très récente, 2022, on n'arrive pas à publier un rapport comme ça, dans les sphères politiques en Belgique ?
Oui, mais il y a plusieurs éléments importants à analyser dans cette affaire. Premièrement, c'était un groupe de dix experts qui devaient, et je faisais partie de ce groupe, qui devait faire, enfin, présenter une base.
C'est finalement un document de plus de six cents pages. Et ici, dans ce pays, en fait, tout est politisé. Ça commençait déjà—
Mh.
Qui va-t-on nommer dans ce groupe ? Les écologistes voulaient avoir leur homme, les communistes, le MR, tout ça voulait, hein.
Et donc cela a un peu biaisé le. Mais j'étais là-dedans. J'ai porté ce—
Et le parti pris, c'est ça.
Oui, oui, oui, oui, oui, c'est ça, hein. Parce que tout le monde voyait le Congo avec, comme vous dites, ses propres, son propre logiciel.
Mh.
Et—
Aussi dans un contexte électoral, alors.
Oui, oui, oui, oui, oui. Et puis, je regrette de devoir dire cela, mais le président de cette commission,
un homme que j'apprécie beaucoup, hein, Wouter De Vriendt, écologiste flamand, ce n'est pas, comme on dit en anglais, un power broker.
Hein, donc c'est moi le président et je vais—
Mh, oui, c'est ça.
Mais—
C'est le cerveau écrasé.
Oui, oui, oui, oui, oui, oui, par hein. Donc, il voulait que tout le monde soit content. Mais dans cette affaire—
Oui.
...rien, on ne peut pas contenter tout le monde.
C'est tellement clivant comme dossier.
Oui, oui, c'est justement ça. Et je pense que c'est ça un peu le drame de cela. Et puis, on a toujours dans l'arrière-tête le fait : bon voilà, qu'est-ce que cela va nous apporter électoralement ?
Oui.
Hein, donc, de tout le monde. Les auditions, quand on était là, c'était incroyable, hein.
Et parfois, par des éléments—
Qu'est-ce qui était incroyable ?
Il y a des gens qui disaient : « Oui, mais écoutez, nous n'allons pas payer pour les méfaits, les crimes du passé. »
D'il y a cent ans, oui.
Mais on n'a jamais demandé cela. Et ce n'était pas ça la question non plus.
Oui, c'est une posture politicienne—
Oui, oui, oui. Donc, ça, non, non, non, non, non, non. Ça, c'est impossible. Et puis,
bon, il y avait aussi, enfin, du côté africain, bon, quelqu'un, Hutu, hein : « Bon voilà, c'est contre Kagamé et les Tutsis.
» Donc tout— oh là là ! On a parfois consacré plus de temps à des discussions de ce genre-là que, disons, aux vraies discussions.
Mh.
Hein, ce passé colonial. Et donc, moi, enfin, je ne regrette pas d'avoir été un des experts, mais j'ai beaucoup, j'ai beaucoup appris.
J'ai beaucoup appris dans le sens que la façon dont les politiciens conçoivent le passé est parfois à l'opposé des conceptions des historiens.
C'est ça qui est dramatique.
Si on veut être très concret—
Mh.
Est-ce que ce sont des politiciens d'un bord en particulier ? Par exemple—
Non, non, non, tout le monde. Non, non, non, non, par exemple—
Je pense par exemple que ceux du Vlaams n'ont pas forcément le même regard, le même prisme que, par exemple, voilà, vous citiez un écologiste.
Oui, oui.
Je pense que le regard qu'on a sur le passé est quand même— la lecture qu'on a du passé est très différente selon le parti dont on parle.
Oui, mais il fallait arranger ça bien avant ça.
Mh.
Les politiciens devaient se mettre d'accord sur ça avant de nous—
Faire travailler.
D'accord.
Donc dire, hein : est-ce qu'il y aura question de réparation morale, matérielle, et cetera, oui ou non ?
Oui, avant d'appeler les experts.
Avant de nous appeler.
Oui.
C'est ça qui était dramatique. Parce qu'on nous posait la question. On, hein— donc pour eux, ce n'était plus important, disons, ces vérités-là, mais le fait : est-ce qu'on devra payer ?
Hein, par exemple, donc sur la restitution—
D'œuvres d'art, de—
Oui, des œuvres d'art, donc, comment dirais-je, de patrimoine ethnographique surtout, et culturel, des Congolais. Ceux de droite, sauf du côté wallon, comprenaient ça.
Ils disaient : « Mh, si 80 % de nos œuvres, de notre patrimoine culturel se trouvait à l'étranger, on n'allait plus dormir.
Effectivement, ce qu'on a pu observer, c'est qu'il y a eu une visite à un moment donné du roi Philippe, accompagné du premier Alexander De Croo, donc Open VLD.
Et effectivement, ça allait dans ce sens-là. Inversement,
les libéraux flamands, donc, et inversement, les libéraux francophones étaient plutôt dans une logique présidée par George-Louis Bouchez, dans une logique de dire : on ne peut surtout pas faire ça.
On ne peut plus rien dire. Il faut qu'on puisse garder tout ça.
Oui, c'est ça. Ça a rendu les choses plus dramatiques.
Une logique très politicienne, une logique de positionnement électoral. Comment est-ce qu'on veut se positionner électoralement ?
Comment est-ce qu'on veut être vu par les électeurs ?
Et donc pas tellement dans une logique de : on veut appeler les experts et les historiens pour avoir une base de travail, pour prendre une décision, mais plutôt : quelle décision pourrait nous bénéficier ?
Quel est le discours qui pourrait nous bénéficier ?
Oui, c'était ça.
Mais malgré tout, le fait que certains discours puissent bénéficier à certains partis ou être inversement contre-productifs dans certaines campagnes électorales montre que toutes ces questions restent très clivantes et que
les Belges, grosso modo, selon leur positionnement politique, selon s'ils sont Flamands ou Bruxellois, Wallons, n'auront pas la même lecture des choses.
Mais ce n'est pas encore fini. Après autant d'années, ce n'est pas encore fini. Parce que moi, je suis maintenant au Congo.
D'ailleurs, c'est la raison pour laquelle je me suis rendu à Kinshasa trois fois, disons, à partir du mois de septembre.
À Kinshasa, les politiciens, c'est-à-dire les parlementaires du Palais du Peuple, ont décidé de créer une commission qui doit s'occuper des réformes de l'enseignement de l'histoire.
Je trouve ça magnifique. Parce que là, c'est ça la question. Donc, ce n'est plus politique, mais voilà. Et cela signifie tout simplement qu'on va regarder les contenus, mais aussi comment implémenter cela dans l'enseignement.
Parce qu'ici, l'enseignement souffre de quoi ? Du fait que ça dépend de la bonne volonté d'un professeur ou d'une professeure pour donner une ou deux heures sur le passé colonial de la Belgique.
Ça reste au mieux des initiatives personnelles, des professeurs qui peuvent être très motivés. Mais les professeurs, le professeur d'histoire, par exemple, dans le secondaire, lorsqu'ils reçoivent leur formation universitaire,
on ne leur en parle pas, par exemple.
Non. Mais c'est encore plus dramatique que ça. J'ai travaillé pendant tout ce temps-là aussi au Musée de Tervuren en tant qu'historien.
À un certain moment, nous étions dix. Maintenant, il y a encore une personne, un historien dans cette section-là. Un. On tient un peu à moi parce que j'y vais régulièrement, on me consulte des trucs comme ça.
Je suis, comme on dit, un chercheur libre, là, au Musée de Tervuren. Mais pour le reste, c'est fini. Donc, le musée, on est en train de transformer le musée tout simplement en une institution muséale.
Le côté scientifique, c'est fini. Ça coûte trop cher, etc.
Oui, c'est ça. C'est dans une logique, ce n'est pas spécifique aux questions coloniales, c'est dans une logique budgétaire, dans une logique de : on veut baisser les coûts un peu partout.
Et donc ça dépend, je suppose, du FNRS, qui est donc un budget fédéral. Et voilà, c'est depuis grosso modo le gouvernement NVA, le gouvernement Michel en 2014.
On sait qu'on a grosso modo très fort—
Et qu'est-ce qu'on voit ? À l'époque, la Belgique avait des africanistes dignes de ce nom. Donc des professeurs d'université, que ça soit le professeur Vellut ici, le professeur pour la politique coloniale, c'était Jean Stengers, etc.
Mais on n'a plus ça. Je constate, donc malgré le fait que je suis un pensionné depuis cinq ans, on vient toujours vers moi pour donner un cours de l'histoire.
C'est un peu en annexe, en marge de tout cela, parce qu'on ne coûte pas beaucoup parce que c'est 10 % des trucs comme ça.
Mais pour le reste, donc ceux qui sont supposés travailler sur l'histoire du Congo belge, d'abord, on voit ça, ils sont des spécialistes des Balkans.
Je ne vais pas citer de noms, mais à Leuven, spécialiste des Balkans et des Indes. Et un peu du Congo. Et c'est des projets, des projets.
Mais ce ne sont pas des gens qui travaillent à cent pour cent sur cette histoire-là. Idem dito à l'Université d'Anvers, à Louvain-la-Neuve.
Et aussi longtemps qu'on ne parvienne pas vraiment à intégrer des cours sur l'Afrique, non seulement l'histoire, mais aussi la sociologie, l'économie, etc.
Si on ne prend pas cela au sérieux, d'ici peu, ça sera complètement perdu. C'est en train de se dissiper.
À quel niveau est-ce que ces décisions se prennent ? Est-ce que c'est des initiatives de chaque faculté d'histoire dans chaque université ou bien est-ce que c'est au niveau communautaire ?
Écoutez, comment sont financées les universités ? C'est toujours avec des enveloppes. Et avec ces enveloppes-là, on dit : Bon, vous vous débrouillez.
Et bien sûr que l'Afrique reste, disons, le frère pauvre de tout cela. C'est évident.
Et est-ce qu'en marge de ça, on n'observe pas, dans ce contexte, voilà— Je pense par exemple à ce qui se passe aux États-Unis, les Black Lives Matter, etc.
Est-ce qu'on n'observe pas un renouveau, un regain d'intérêt pour les questions de domination, les questions coloniales, par exemple, chez les jeunes étudiants qui ferait qu'ils auraient envie de s'intéresser à ces sujets-là ou bien est-ce que—
Oui, mais il faut dire, est-ce qu'on a des cours de l'histoire du monde arabe ?
Oui. Mmh.
Non. Parce que encore une fois, hein, je souligne, l'Europe, c'est toujours moi, moi, moi. C'est égocentrisme et eurocentrisme, hein.
Donc en tant que dominant, donc des choses comme ça. Est-ce qu'on doit connaître les Africains ou leur histoire ?
Ben non, ben non. Il y a, mine de rien, la Chine s'intéresse beaucoup plus à l'Afrique, même au niveau des universités, que la Belgique, hein.
Ils ont aussi un intérêt économique dans le sens où—
C'est ça. Oui, oui, oui. Oui, mais moi, je veux bien.
Un partenaire de choix pour les Chinois.
Oui, moi, je veux bien. Il s'agit des intérêts partagés. Je veux— hein, moi, je comprends.
Hein, donc, il faut mieux connaître l'Afrique pour pouvoir commercer avec l'Afrique. Et c'est aux Africains de bien connaître les Européens aussi pour bien commercer avec eux.
C'est ça qui manque totalement. C'est ça qui manque.
Donc vous, vous dites qu'en Europe, on reste très eurocentrés.
Oui, oui, oui.
J'ai malgré tout l'impression d'observer, dans, voilà, dans les personnes que je peux rencontrer, une grande frustration par rapport au fait qu'on n'a pas eu ces cours en secondaire.
Ah oui, oui, oui.
On est même nombreux à se dire : ce n'est pas normal.
Oui, mais les politiciens, hein, s'en foutent de ça.
Mmh.
Si cela ne rapporte pas, dans leurs yeux, ils ne vont pas, hein. Moi, écoutez, c'est ma dernière année comme professeur d'un cours d'histoire de l'Afrique et des cultures africaines.
Bon, je ne sais pas. Mon successeur, ça sera qui ? Hein ? Je ne sais pas. C'est difficile. C'est à cause de ça qu'on tient encore à moi.
Hein, bon voilà, mais je crains fort.
Donc la situation est plutôt en phase de s'empirer.
Ah oui, oui, oui, oui, oui. Oui, oui. Oui, oui. Oui, oui. Là, je suis— ce n'est pas par pessimisme, hein.
Oui, c'est factuel.
C'est factuel. C'est factuel.
C'est assez choquant, je dois dire. On va tout doucement donc s'approcher de la fin de cet entretien. J'ai encore quelques questions.
Donc, je pense à un épisode qui a eu lieu donc en août 2018, donc le Pukkelpop, où on a pu entendre des chants dans la foule, hein, de Congo Is For Dance, le Congo est à nous, avec parallèlement à ça—
Coupez les blancs.
Encore des discours qui avaient tendance à expliquer que le Congo se portait mieux lorsque l'occupant belge était là.
Est-ce qu'aujourd'hui, vraiment, des générations plus tard après la domination belge au Congo, est-ce qu'on observe encore, voilà, les relents de ce qu'on décrivait plus tôt, c'est-à-dire-
Oui, mais moi-
Cette considération raciste, coloniale vis-à-vis du Congo. Est-ce qu'il reste des traces de ça ?
Moi, j'ai considéré ça comme, comment dirais-je-
Anecdotique ou ?
Pas anecdotique, parce que ça ne peut pas être anecdotique. Mais donc des petits gens, de 10 fois rien-
Oui, c'est ça.
Entre guillemets, des fumiers de la société qui se sont amusés avec cela. Et donc, je refuse de généraliser cela.
C'est-à-dire que-
Je refuse. Je refuse de généraliser cela.
Ça s'inscrit dans un contexte où l'extrême droite nationaliste, raciste en Flandre-
L'eurocentrisme dont je parle. Le risque d'avoir ça est grand dans l'avenir parce que eux ne vont plus connaître l'Afrique d'une manière sérieuse.
Donc si à l'université, il n'y a plus ce cours-là ou-
De ne pas mieux répéter l'histoire.
Oui, oui. Et dans l'enseignement secondaire, dans les humanités, que voulez-vous ? Il y a toujours des gens qui vont s'amuser avec cela.
Et en fait, on aurait dû utiliser ce moment-là pour dire : on va maintenant prendre ça au sérieux, l'Afrique, etc.
Mais donc c'est tout de suite la justice, des trucs comme ça. Mais la solution, à mon avis, c'est un peu plus d'Afrique dans l'enseignement,
surtout dans l'enseignement supérieur, là où sont formés nos instituteurs et nos professeurs dans les humanités.
C'est ça qui est, à mon avis, qui est dramatique. Quand je regarde autour de moi, c'est presque fini.
Mmh.
Et à l'époque, donc on a des bourses Erasmus, etc. Mais pas pour aller en Afrique. Un peu l'Afrique du Nord, peut-être, l'Afrique du Sud, mais pour le reste, non.
Donc les gens, c'est l'Europe de l'Est, c'est surtout ça. Et la Méditerranée, l'Espagne, le Portugal, l'Italie, la France, etc.
C'est tout. C'est tout. Mais donc les contacts, les expériences. Parce que je demande ça à chaque fois que je commence mes cours au début de l'année académique.
Je dis : bon, qui a déjà été en Afrique ?
Personne.
C'est rare.
Ouais.
C'est rare. Si c'est l'Afrique, l'Égypte, en tant que touriste, ou la Tanzanie, etc. Mais pas le Congo, pas le Rwanda, pas le Burundi.
Non, non, non, non. Ou l'Afrique du Sud, parce que parfois, on a de la famille là-bas. Donc c'est tout.
C'est fini. C'est fini. Jusqu'en 1992, les jeunes pouvaient encore aller travailler dans le secteur du développement au Congo pendant deux ans, au lieu donc de ce service militaire.
Maintenant, c'est fini. Il n'y a plus de service militaire et il n'y a plus d'occasion pour nos jeunes d'aller travailler et enseigner, d'entrer en contact avec les Africains, je dirais, vivants et survivants de cette époque coloniale.
C'est ça qui est dramatique. Moi, je vois ça autour de moi. Moi, j'allais régulièrement donner cours aussi, aider volontairement mes copains,
mes collègues congolais, mais maintenant, ce n'est plus le cas.
Ceux qui doivent enseigner n'ont pas du tout été au Congo. Et la connaissance des langues aussi.
Moi, je peux encore lire des documents écrits, rédigés en lingala. Mais si c'est en swahili, c'est quelqu'un d'autre. Mais on a,
disons, chez les Congolais, oui, parce que nous sommes issus de cette société-là, des gens qui peuvent encore, qui comprennent, qui parlent, qui s'expriment encore en lingala, en swahili ou en chiluba, etc.
Et qui peuvent faire des enquêtes, parce que - et ici, ça doit toujours être en français ou en anglais, etc.
Une langue ou des langues que le Bas-Congolais ne maîtrise pas. Est-ce qu'on peut interviewer ta mère ? Mais il faut le faire en lingala.
Oui, mais on ne maîtrise pas. Je dis : si c'est en français, elle ne va pas comprendre ou mal comprendre ce que vous dites, elle.
Donc c'est un peu ça. C'est un peu ça.
Et encore une fois, je ne suis pas pessimiste. J'espère qu'un jour, il y aura quand même un politicien qui verra la lumière, la lumière africaine là, et qui dit : bon écoutez, il faut faire quelque chose.
Mais à l'heure actuelle, c'est le déclin total au musée de Tervuren et dans l'enseignement supérieur, c'est... Et d'autant plus que moi, mes dernières publications, deux livres, chaque fois quatre cents pages.
Écoutez, en néerlandais, on en a vendu presque quatre mille, ce qui est énorme pour un livre d'histoire sur ça. Mais c'était devenu très populaire auprès des étudiants.
Quel livre exactement ?
Mon livre sur le Congo de dix-huit cent septante-six à dix-neuf cent quatorze, donc en deux volumes. Parce que c'est dans une langue que les étudiants comprennent, maîtrisent.
Pour le reste, moi aussi, je suis obligé d'enseigner en anglais. Mais ce n'est pas ma langue maternelle. Je ne peux pas, les tournures, les-
C'est souvent comme ça dans les séries universitaires.
Oui, oui, oui, c'est justement ça. Mais là, les étudiants sont contents. Ah, c'est dans leur langue,
etc. Et ça va encore du côté néerlandophone, mais du côté francophone, on a - depuis Vellut, le professeur Vellut, c'est fini.
C'est fini l'histoire-
Oui.
De l'Afrique.
Dernière question avant qu'on soit obligé de se quitter, malheureusement, même si, voilà, je tenais à dire que je m'attriste à vos côtés vis-à-vis de la détérioration des cours d'histoire, en particulier liés au Congo.
Donc en préparant cet épisode, j'étais à la recherche de l'invité idéal à interviewer. Donc je suis ravi de vous avoir trouvé.
Au cours de mes recherches, j'ai à un moment donné été en contact avec une université. Je vais pas pointer du doigt, mais je posais la question de savoir qui serait l'intervenant intéressant à inviter.
On m'a proposé une série de noms, de professeurs d'histoire à gauche, à droite, voilà. Et au terme de cet appel téléphonique, j'ai dit : mais tiens, est-ce que tous les noms que vous me proposez sont des blancs ?
Est-ce que ce ne serait pas important, intéressant, adéquat pour parler de l'histoire coloniale, de parler du Congo, d'inviter quelqu'un qui est noir ?
Et bon, la personne m'a dit non, du moment que le chercheur est neutre, ce n'est pas important. Alors, je vais vous poser la question à vous.
Est-ce que, parce que vous me parliez tout à l'heure de radicalité, pour reprendre vos mots, pour vous décrire.
Est-ce que vous avez le sentiment, quand vous regardez vos collègues chercheurs, chercheuses, professeurs d'histoire, que vous avez le sentiment d'avoir un regard, un, oui, un angle différent comparé à eux ?
L'angle différent, c'est-à-dire, on est plus sensible-
Oui.
Aux expériences des Congolais. Ça, c'est... Et neutre. Bah écoutez.
Je ne sais pas ce que ça veut dire, neutre.
Oui, mais c'est toujours comme ça, quand il s'agit de l'histoire du Congo, un Noir ne peut pas être neutre parce qu'il est noir et il va parler-
Et inversement, les-
Oui, oui. Et le blanc, il est neutre.
Et les femmes, quand on parle de féminisme, ne peuvent pas être neutres. Par contre, les hommes-
Oui, oui, c'est toujours. Je trouve ça honteux et je dis ça aussi-
C'est l'image dominante.
Oui, oui, oui, oui, oui, oui, oui, oui. Donc c'est toujours, ne peut pas être neutre. Mais bon, voilà qu'est-ce qu'il représente alors ?
Donc est-ce que vous avez déjà utilisé des documents dans des langues indigènes congolaises, etc. Oui ou non ?
Pour comprendre, bien comprendre les autres. Est-ce que vous avez déjà travaillé pendant un certain temps dans ces pays-là ?
Il y en a très peu. Moi, autour de moi, je ne vois presque personne. Il y a un à Leuven qui dit : « Je suis né au Congo ».
Mais qu'est-ce que cela signifie ? Moi aussi, je suis né au Congo.
Ma mère est née au Congo.
Mais ouais, ouais. Ça ne dit rien.
Non.
Ça ne dit rien du tout. Ce n'est pas parce que. Si c'est un Blanc né au Congo, ah là, il peut être neutre.
Mais si c'est un Noir né au Congo, ah non, il ne peut pas être.
C'est finalement la crainte presque de voir-
Oui.
Une grille de lecture blanche dominante remise en question.
C'est ça, c'est ça, c'est ça.
Le neutre, c'est le status quo, finalement.
Oui, oui. Et il y va de la défense de leurs propres intérêts, de ne plus être reconnu comme un africaniste ou un spécialiste de l'histoire du Congo.
Et c'est bon avec les Congolais, etc. Est-ce qu'il existe un autre terme pour ça ? Jalousie ou quoi que ce soit, mais encore une fois, égocentrisme et eurocentrisme.
Très bien. Mais écoutez, je vous remercie pour ces plus de septante minutes passées avec moi, Mathieu Zana Etambala.
Ce fut un plaisir. Je pense qu'on a eu l'occasion d'apprendre beaucoup. Je pense que nos auditeurs, auditrices auront appris beaucoup aujourd'hui.
Merci beaucoup et je vous dis à très bientôt pour un prochain épisode.
Merci, merci à vous. Merci.
Un grand merci à Mathieu Zana Aziza Etambala. Je suis vraiment content d'avoir pu trouver quelqu'un d'aussi passionné, critique et impliqué dans ces questions.
Si le Congo belge vous intéresse, il est l'auteur de plusieurs livres à ce sujet. Celui dont on a parlé pendant l'interview n'est disponible qu'en néerlandais.
Malheureusement, il s'agit de Veroverd, bezet, gekoloniseerd: Congo 1876-1914. Encore une fois, il est professeur en Flandre, mais il a d'autres livres en français.
On en a un tout petit peu parlé, mais on a rapidement mis ça de côté. Est-ce qu'il y a eu un génocide des Congolais sous le joug de Léopold II ?
Vous vous rappelez peut-être de ma discussion avec Marie Pelletier il y a quelques mois, quand on parle avec des historiens, ils insistent très fort généralement sur le sens des mots, surtout par approximation.
Et en l'occurrence, le consensus est plutôt de dire qu'il ne s'agissait vraiment pas d'un génocide puisque faire disparaître les Congolais n'a jamais été l'objectif en soi.
Or, c'est vraiment un critère central dans la définition. Si vous avez le moindre retour, n'hésitez pas, vous pouvez me joindre à contact@septenteminutes.be.
L'adresse est en description. Et enfin, même si pour certains, je sais que vous m'écoutez peut-être dans un lointain futur, je vais quand même vous souhaiter une magnifique nouvelle année et beaucoup de succès et de bonheur en 2025.
Pour ma part, je peux déjà vous promettre qu'il y aura une grande surprise pour vous dans quelques mois. Je vous embrasse et je vous dis à très bientôt. Salut salut !